Weihnachtsmann ich habe dir einen langen
Brief geschrieben
richtig lecker Leute
[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute gibt es
Spekulatius schnitten die werden richtig
lecker und sehr sehr einfaches Anfänger
geeignet zuallererst solltet ihr eure
Butter 2 Stunden vorher oder eine Stunde
vorher aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen damit
sie schön weich wird und ich schreibe
euch wie immer alle ganz genau
Mengenangaben natürlich unten in die
Infobox dann wird das Video einfach
nicht so lang atme ich kann sofort
loslegen und ihr könnt euch einfach
alles screenshotten einkaufen und das
ganze nachmachen so ich benutze hat
meine Küchenmaschine und ihr könnt wenn
ihr mögt natürlich auch das
Handrührgerät verwenden aber so habe ich
das Gefühl steht dass ich einfach
fluffiger auf da gebe ich jetzt noch
Zucker mit dazu und Vanille Extrakt und
dann 3 Minuten lang dick cremig schlagen
lassen
[Musik]
so mit dem rührhakenaufsatz klappt das
ganze auch wunderbar dann nimmt er sich
nämlich auch die Seiten mit und das
ganze ist jetzt schön hell cremig
sondern als nächstes kommen die Eier
dazu da mache ich jetzt einfach so dass
ich sie vorab hier einmal in diese
Schüssel hier hineinschlagen dann stelle
ich auch sicher dass da keine
Schalenreste mit drin sind ich habe
unter ein Video mal Ärger bekommen von
euch weil ich das direkt reingeschlagen
habe und ähm ja man sagt ja aber was
wenn da jetzt eine Schale mit drin ist
oder sowas ich muss sagen ich passe
eigentlich immer ganz gut auf und bin da
ganz gut drin aber wir können immer in
so eine Schale vorab aufschlagen und
dann nach und nach reingeben dann habt
ihr erst das Gefühl es verbindet sich
nie und dann einfach weiter schlagen und
irgendwann verbindet sich das und dann
kommen die trockenen Zutaten rein
[Musik]
so kleiner Tipp an der Stelle noch wenn
eure Eier jetzt zimmerwarm gewesen wären
dann hätte sich das noch besser
verbunden meine waren jetzt frisch aus
dem Kühlschrank sondern natürlich doof
aber da habe ich nicht weit rein gedacht
und das kann ich euch als Tipp mitgeben
und jetzt Siebe ich die trockenen
Zutaten hinein ich habe hier die
Klassiker also Mehl Backkakao Backpulver
und Spekulatius Gewürz da könnt ihr
alternativ auch Zimt nehmen
ihr könnt auch ganz weglassen also wenn
ihr es gar nicht möglich ist Gewürz und
Zimt ganz weg aber wir machen ja
spekulati Schnitten von daher gehe ich
schon davon aus dass ihr das mögt
[Musik]
jetzt hat man das Gefühl oha wie viel
trockene Zutat ist das im Vergleich zu
den flüssigen man denkt sich so dass
doch Thomas aber dann rührt ihr einfach
ein paar Sekunden und nur so lange bis
es sich verbunden hat und nicht zu lange
und dann werdet ihr merken es wird ein
richtig schöner homogener Teig und dann
können wir den auch schon Backen
so Teig ist ready Ofen ist vorgeheizt
auf 180 Grad Ober und Unterhitze und ich
habe jetzt hier ein Lochblech mit
Backpapier oben drüber und darüber
meinen Backrahmen so und da könnt ihr
dann einfach super Platz sparen einfach
die Enden zusammenstecken und dann
gibt's noch einen Trick da könnt ihr
dann einfach Spekulatius Kekse auf den
Boden legen damit ihr halt keine
irgendwie zerschneiden müsst könnt ihr
auf dem Boden legen und dann gucken wie
groß eure Backrahmen sein sollte
aber sage ich euch gleich auch natürlich
sollte man so ein bisschen die Maße auch
beachten also plus minus ein Zentimeter
ist okay wenn ihr jetzt zu
unterschiedliche Maße habt als jetzt im
Rezept könnt ihr das einfach sich auf
die Backzeit noch mal auswirken daher
werde ich euch die Maße gleich verraten
damit ihr das auch so eins zu eins
nachmachen könnt guck mal das ist jetzt
der Vorteil ich ziehe das jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen höher damit meine
kekchen genau da reinpassen gibt's
eigentlich welche unter euch die die
Kekse Socken also ich bin nicht so also
ich mag lieber immer damit irgendwas zu
backen Schicht Desserts Kuchen das
gleiche die gleiche Diskussion hatte ich
ja mit euch unter meinem Video mit den
löffelbiscrets wo ich da auch was mit
löffelbis gemacht hatte und einiger
geschrieben doch Kiki ich esse die auch
mal so zum Kaffee und ich bin der
Meinung dafür sind eigentlich nur zum
Zubereiten und zum Backen da
ist sehr zufrieden gerade so Maße
verrate ich euch 28 x 22 cm jetzt kann
ich hier auch die Klemmung festmachen so
falls ihr baustellengeräusche hört von
unserer Haustür ist seit einem Jahr eine
Baustelle juhu
einmal abnehmen die Kekse wieder
aufsammeln und dann lege ich den
Backrahmen wieder drauf und ähm streicht
mein Teig darüber und sprechen dann
schön glatt und dann wird er im Backofen
gar gebacken
[Musik]
unser Kuchenboden ist frisch aus dem
Ofen raus und wir machen jetzt die
zweite Schicht es wird mehrere Schichten
geben die zweite Schicht besteht aus
Kirschen ich finde nichts schreit mehr
nach Winter als Kirschen und deswegen
habe ich mir die jetzt hier auch schon
abtropfen lassen ihr braucht nicht das
ganze Wasser also dieses diese
Flüssigkeit es ist zu viel ihr könnt es
für andere Projekte verwenden ich habe
mir nur ein bisschen was abgeschöpft
hier in meinen Topf und da kommt jetzt
noch Speisestärke hinzu
verrühre ich jetzt erstmal Klümpchen
frei und dann wird der Herd
eingeschaltet und das ganze könnt ihr
dann einmal aufkochen lassen Zucker gebe
ich auch noch dazu wenn wir das manchmal
nicht süß genug ist und dann kommt die
Kirschen später mit dazu das ganze wird
er aufgekocht damit es ein dick durch
die Stärke und dann habt ihr so eine
zweite Schicht die könnte auch ruhig
noch den lauwarmem Boden geben
[Musik]
so man sieht auf jeden Fall wie schnell
das ganze anlegt ich gebe jetzt schon
mal die mit dazu ich fand ein Glas
einfach zu wenig die Flüssigkeit von
einem Glas hätte ausgereicht aber die
Kirschen nicht das werden wir dann zu
wenig ich will dass man in jedem Biss so
dieses volle fruchtige Erlebnis hat so
einmal so durchrühren warum ich die
Kirschen nicht vorab schon dazu gebe
sonst werden sie zu matschig da gebe ich
sie erst am Ende mit dazu das ganze ist
jetzt schön fest es wird auch nach dem
Herd noch fester also können wir unseren
Kuchenboden holen und das Ganze einmal
drauf verstreichen
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt die nächste Schicht und
zwar ist es Sahne mit Vanillegeschmack
dann nehme ich einfach kalte Schlagsahne
wichtig ist dass die ganz kalt aus dem
Kühlschrank kommt eure Schüssel und der
Schneebesen auf das sollten jetzt auch
nicht gerade warm abgespült worden sein
also auch schön kalt so und dann schlage
ich das mit meiner Küchenmaschine gebt
gerne auch schon Vanilleextrakt mit dazu
und dann kann ich während des schlägt
Sahnefest dazu geben und dann bist du
eigentlich die Schicht auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die steif geschlagene Sahne kommt jetzt
auf die abgekühlte Oberfläche jetzt ist
natürlich ganz wichtig dass sie
abgekühlt ist sonst würde euch die Sahne
dahinschmelzen und dann verstreiche ich
das nur noch glatt mit meiner
Winkelpalette und dann kommt
abschließend noch unsere
spekulatius-kekse und Topf eigentlich
wäre es cool wenn ihr das dann noch mal
so ein bisschen ziehen lassen weil dann
werden die Kekse weich so eine halbe
Stunde im Kühlschrank weil er die Kekse
ziehen dann die Feuchtigkeit der Sahne
auf und dann werden sie auch noch mal
schön weich das mag ich ja selbst total
gerne ansonsten könnte es auch sofort
servieren und das ganze hält sich bis zu
drei Tage im Kühlschrank das heißt ihr
könnt es ganz locker auch am Vortag
vorbereiten und dann hältst immer noch
darauf die nächsten zwei Tage also drei
insgesamt und dann kommt auch schon weg
Test
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ja gerade noch voll so
gefreut als die Kamera aus war
das sieht heftig aus bitte
backpapiere
[Musik]
Mensch danke
du liebst doch nicht Weihnachtsmann
Weihnachtsmann ich habe dir eine lange
Bild geschrieben
dürfen wir dann endlich probieren ja
Spekulatius ich muss sagen ich habe ja
gesagt wenn ihr den Keks weich haben
wollt müsst ihr warten und das noch mal
einziehen lassen was ich jetzt nicht
gemacht
so eine Kreuzung zwischen Pferd und
gepaart
aber ich kann das jetzt nicht durchgehen
weg also normalerweise wäre es jetzt
aber
okay es klappt nicht so gut
wie gesagt also geduld geduld dann wird
der Keks doch weiß probiert einfach mal
Leute das ist so lecker ich mag
eigentlich ne aber so ein Kuchen und
wenn du das machst dann schmeckt sie
anders
ich bin auch nicht so ich will das auch
niemals zwischen so nee das ist niemals
also Langeweile haben
muss sagen es ist halt ein wirklich ein
fluffiger Boden und ich bin froh dass
ich zu den Kirschen halt noch ein
bisschen Zucker gegeben habe und zu
Sahne gar nicht weil die Sahne ich finde
es perfekt ich finde es gut dass es
nicht zu süß schmeckt das schmeckt
einfach so gerade richtig süß und nicht
zu süß also
[Musik]
richtig lecker Leute so ein Kuchen
nee da habe ich Vanille rein aber ähm
Spekulatius in den Boden
oder also nach Geschmack merke ich das
persönlich ja klar wäre dann könnte man
mitnehmen wir können ja gleich noch mal
ziehen lassen und noch ein Stückchen
Essen
das gibt noch mal so
auf jeden Fall dann lieber einziehen
lassen genau würde ich auch sagen
richtig gut Leute macht es unbedingt
nach und ganz ehrlich 30 40 Minuten
fertig
auf jeden Fall also Leute nachmachen
unbedingt nachmachen und zum Abschied
singen kann sie euch jetzt noch ein
Sternchen von Weihnachtsmann und Co KG
aber er war eigentlich eine
GmbH geworden weil er wollte weniger
Steuern zahlen genau dann soll es
eigentlich eine Holding werden aber es
hat euch zugelassen weil die wussten
dass er verlassen viel Geld verdient die
wollten weniger Steuern kann
in Deutschland ach so
also warum ist denn hier Dubai
ausgewandern
okay
tschüss bitte beatboxe im Hintergrund
oder nicht weil
[Musik]